hello and welcome to this video it was a
bit of a late recalling start playing
errands in a russell limo okay we'll see
whoa what is that age three and
ninety-three that's f'd okay I don't
understand that set up what is white
after here but we have to call it black
just has a central advantage now usually
you want to try to place the three NT
form well yeah I can take right that
doesn't it doesn't work at all so rook
takes a three or yet it's pretty good
time and it's let's do it Bishop takes
h3 is just winning a porn but that I
think is even stronger
we should be five forever something that
that he has
yeah maybe I shouldn't have taken on age
three now that I think of it equal have
taken okay so i should have just them I
should have just taken on on atria grab
the pawn this might be good for black
but it's also working quite a bit we
should f6 and then I go and do give aid
for later 9h form
9h for now is pretty pretty tough to
meet
can you cannot cover it almost I don't
really see how
just 9h for next move probably has to
play some rookie three then to just give
given exchange
yeah it's a desperation move but
understandable cannot just sit around so
I don't see a movie theater white so um
[Music]
Knight takes rook takes rook chicks in
tix somewhere on sip every file I've got
cringy form 19th at the end a FB should
reform for the maid so yes I can judge
you cannot take on c 5 45 now Quincy for
the win okay check check yes
check check so how to do it here okay
easiest assessor is accrued some Queens
rate as easy as light really click on 2
g-3 also anyway it's I've got a ton of
porn zone it was a bit of a strange
setup because I mean I know it sounds
like a broken record but I don't
understand like spending 10 seconds on
this and it's just a bad setup for white
it's just bad because you don't have any
particular idea what to do and you
should play see 3d form if black takes
with the beep on the combination of h3
and 93 just doesn't work I mean of
course you can play that if you know
that perfectly its kind of equal maybe
but then just one or two bear more
barrels and then you're out and that we
saw in the game the engine wants to go a
three and then be three I mean I'm up
for a five so I was thinking maybe some
sort of f4 for white maybe yeah it gets
tricky already I know I took yeah and D
takes is more interesting and because he
has some counter play against my D porn
I was still thinking I should just do it
I think he I cannot do this however that
that looks that doesn't work at sd-6
sorry d 6 is too weak I can do oh I can
win the porn here this is not clear ever
okay now f4 at the engine actually likes
white so that is an option I can also go
F form that's something that also
briefly considered the TM this takes a
while so it wasn't that bad
oops we elected just that just that just
won't work so do this and I'm not sure
about the capture on 83 with hindsight
the engine gives 95 and I kind of kind
of understand down it's not really
necessary to grab that pond so n95 I
didn't like you to see form okay I
computers typically fearless but I
wasn't sure if the night comes here how
i do how I continue to attack this is
why I went here and now taking a 95 it
was better than Bishop g5 it's more or
less calm ok now the thread Queen g4 is
too strong I mean yeah yeah yeah we
should be six was even a bit stronger
bit yeah just a fairly shiny clean with
I was thinking a check and tiki I could
have could have taken he three and then
take what was easy am but it's enough
Queen ending with three extra points
this a bit to be too much and still not
I already thought the openings complete
rubbish but it isn't that bad it seems
yeah the reason why I fall it is bad is
actually because of this thing but that
isn't so clear I mean he takes is in
fact I'm quite interesting it's a bit
weird or for all of it but that somehow
somehow this is this compensation for
white and and thats it's true I can't do
this but here I mean this is this
dangerous but he will have some counter
play for sure I can as the engine gives
prepare before or also some see 3d form
I mean I'm not sure that this is any
good you know just pushing everything
forward and let white clay in the center
ok thanks for watching